T
FEELS FOREIGTH
IS SUPPOSED  W
S IN YOUR
SEEM SO TABLE ANTHE TIS E ST
KAT THE J IBEA HUMAN G. EVEN TD
PEN  TREAT PEOPLE WITHIONS
ACCURATE INFORMATITH
GOAL.
UMAN AIMES
OU'RE ANSWERING THE
QUESTION, THE SA QUESTION
PREMISE OF A QUESTION IS BASEDC
B
FRUSTRATING.NO
PEOPLE SEE M OCCASIONALLY I HAVA
HUMANITY. O THOS OFALSEHOODS CO
MAX WHICH DOES GET CALLED ON.
KNOW A LOT OF LIBERALS DON'T
THFOCALLED WHY DO YOU CALL OFO
E IS
POINT
O PROJECT TO TWITHETS, T EDVIEWA
AND WHEN HTO GOV
ANANS TO A RANGE OF OUTLETS,E,HO
INTEREST, SO THAT IS EXACTLY  I
TRS  W DUTY TO DEFEND TH
S  DO YOU EL
YOU'VE MADE ANPRH
, DEFEATING THE
F RYAY
INY TO FOCUS OHIS ADMINITI
UNDERVALUG
INTELLCE OF THE AMERICAN
WHENES OFALSE OR A
IPOME
DETAILHA T TO DO O
OUR BE BINFORMATIVE,EXAIAND
HO A A LAW, S F
COUNO
RESPOND ASSESSMENT IS OF OULITT
UL
TRWIC IN FIVE
MONTHS.
IT IS GOG
ANTHING WE'LEP
WORKING ON EVERY DAY. WANT TALK
MO O.
Y HAVEN'T YOU HE
ISYO MY ERENCE. INTERE
POCKET THAT MARTHA SD
HAMPBU QUEIOWEEKALWAYS AOST NG I
EXPE THAT LLO
BE THEE.
>> AND IN A FORMAL PRESS
CHOSEN NOT T GIV H
IS THAT AN ATTEMPT TO LOWER THE
GEG  CONTROL,OIT REIGN TRIP ANDG
MILLIONS OF AMERANCK
I DON'T KNOW WHAT
BUT THERE IS AN UNITY
SEVERAL TIMES A WEEK FOR THE
E AN E
UEIOPORTERS.IST AL
CONFERENUTT MAY BE  THE PUBLIC,
>> I FIGUREDOU THAT.
BE OOF RAU WERENN COMMENTATOR IO
WH Y L DE FROM CNN ANDW O  NOW?
>>A LOT.
WHENTAORK, YOU DO SPEN
LOT OFIMSIG PREPARED TO GIVER
T ON A BAKING NEWS ISSUE
OR AN ISSUE THATLTIMD THAT IS
CERATION FORN FRONAMA
AT THE BRIEFING AND
THERE ARE ALSO A FEW PEOPL
N THAT SET WIT
IN P
FF MINE.
S SOTIS AT I RS OR AINQUESTI
D PLEASUREF
ING IN TTO
INCLUDING SERVING AT THE STATE T
.
>> WELL AN
THE LIBERAL BLOG GO LIKETHIS, J
QUESTIONER.
CA
EW N NARRATIVE AND PEOPLE
IT MIGHT. 'M NOTE THAT IHE COU
>> I'M NOT PUTTINGMEBILITY
NOT TOLLOWHE BRI
TOA FORUPR
INATIOSE
DEPARTMENT SPOK
THME THEY WEREEPRESE
ASKING ME HE THINK GOVERNMENT.
ATROO TIME
BUT I HAVE AITY TO
PUICURE ING ACTE
THE PRESQUESTIONS THAT
ARE PROPDA N
GIVIM INACCURATE>> APE INACCURA
>> LOOK, THERERE RANGE OF YS TON
UDING THE PLATFORMS, HOW
THEYSE TRACKING
CERTAINLY  IY N THAT IS GOINTO I
FRIDAYHO IID ON
E  KNOW A LOABOUT ERIDS
PRETTY UNLIKOIY  APPROACH
OV NEXYEARS.SEE.
BUT E
E PLATFORMS COULD TAKE
INITIATIVE OR TAKE STEPS TO
AN
IS NOT GETTING OR THE GLOB
NOT
TENF FORER P.R. PROFESSIONALS
O FO
CONTEXT, TN  D  STAY AS CLOSTS P
RSLE TO PR
THAND IT SOMETIMES IT IS NOTE
THAN TO POLICYINING AN UD COMMU
ED IN POLITICS LIKE
UL
E TRYING T
DO.
I KEEPROD IN THAT BUT
THDES SO ID KIND OF PULL ANDSIE
DVIT ALS
TO ASK AND PUSH O TH RY DAY T RE
W THEY WANT M
ATION AND GIVE MORATN, JOB.S TO,
PUBLIC.N'T PROVIDE EVER
L AS T
HAPPG  PRI OR A
PRR A NATIONALRITY ISSUE AT PLA.
THAT IS A PUSH AND PTHPU PULL.
PART OF OUR CRTHING FRKLG
OM
THAT SENDS AD THAT WE'RE NFRAID.
WE'RE GOING TO NOW PROJECTVEOU
TRIP NEX
D MENTION THAT
PRE-TAPEWI BEFORE THE ABT R
THE NEW YORK TIMES."
HED
I DIASWH P
BR OC
BUT FIRST SOMESOL
QUON
>> YOUTOLD DAVLEROD THAT YOU E O
YEAR PARTLY BECAUSE IT IS A D T
WHEN YOU ENVISION HANDING IT
F E PRESIDENHE ME TO SERVE IN TT
ER J TR
Y 365.
I THINK WHAT CONVEYING T
D ISHAISAN OPPORTUNITY, ONE  T T
UP GIVE OTHER
SHINE.BE THE
PRESCHOOL BUTS IS A JOB OF A LO
THRECIATKING YOU'RE ND I'M NOT
YOU HAIT
ALL BIGGER THAINDIVIALI ND YOU O
THE SPECOFHT NOW.
IN THE MIDST OF EMIC.ATRIEFINL .
WHEN WILL THBRO NORMAL, 100% HE.
WEG TO N PROCESS HERE WITH BRIN